RORY PETTY: Hi.
And welcome to Alerting
and Cloud Monitoring.
My name is Rory.
And I'm a Product Manager
for Cloud Monitoring.
And I'm joined by Syed, who
is a software engineer, who
also works on cloud monitoring.
So today, we're going
to talk about how
you create alerts,
what types of metrics
are available to alert on.
We'll delve a little bit into
the metric and resource model
in Cloud Monitoring.
And we'll show a couple
of demos that present
different alerting concepts.
So Cloud Monitoring is
part of the Cloud Operation
Suite at Google.
Theis core infrastructure
powers not only Google Cloud,
but all of internal Google.
So you can build your operations
workflows with confidence
on top of our
Cloud Ops products.
You might be familiar
with the term Stackdriver.
That was previously the
name for the monitoring
product in Google Cloud.
We've since rebranded it to
Google Cloud Monitoring just
to further emphasize that we
are the primary monitoring
and operations, suite of
tools, for all of Google Cloud.
So you can find alerting by
going to the Hamburger menu
in the upper-left-hand
corner of the Cloud console,
clicking it, scrolling down
to the Operations section,
selecting Monitoring
and selecting Alerting.
In alerting, you'll
find the ability
to create other policies.
You'll see incidents that
have been created from alerts.
And you'll also see
notification channels,
which let you route the
alerts to the correct person
or system.
So what is an Alert Policy?
Alert Policies let you
define a set of conditions
that will generate a
notification whenever
that event is triggered.
The notification can optionally
contain documentation
and metadata to provide
additional information
to the person
receiving the alert.
Alert notifications can be
sent to a variety of channels,
including email, SMS,
Slack, PagerDuty, Webhooks,
Pub/Sub, and more.
So to create an
Alert Policy, you
click the Create
Alert Policy button,
and you Add a Condition.
So as you can see here,
the first option you have
is to select your
resource or metric type.
And so that begs the question,
what types of metrics
are available to alert on?
All Google Cloud services
emit a variety of metrics.
That includes Compute Engine,
GKE, Cloud SQL, pretty much
all of the services.
So there's a good selection
of metrics to choose from.
There are also different
types of metrics,
for example, custom metrics.
These are application-specific
metrics that you define
and collect to capture
information that the built-in
GCP metrics cannot.
So these can be engineering
or business metrics,
for example, account
of returning,
user checkouts in an
e-commerce system.
You can also collect
log-based metrics,
which are based on the
content of log entries,
for example, the
number of log entries
that contain a
particular message.
Or you can even extrapolate
and see your other information
reported in your log entries.
Cloud Monitoring
and Logging also
have agents available
that allow you
to collect a range of
metrics that are not
covered by GCP core metrics.
That includes, for
example, memory usage,
disk allocation, et cetera.
And lastly, you can collect
uptime metrics, which
are produced by uptime checks,
which send probes from six
different regions worldwide
to monitor your web pages,
your APIs, and your services.
And they emit metrics
for liveliness, latency,
and several other features
that you can alert on.
We also support a broad range of
metrics, both for other clouds,
and for the most popular open-
and closed-source applications.
So no matter what
applications you're running
or what infrastructure
you're on,
Google Cloud Monitoring is
able to support you, both,
for monitoring and alerting.
So we're going to
talk a little bit
about the metric
and resource model.
And I'm going to
hand it over to Syed.
SYED ASHRAFULLA: In
Cloud Monitoring,
every time series is identified
by two things, the metric
and the resource.
The resource is what you
are trying to monitor.
It can be a virtual machine.
It can be a load balancer.
It can even be something
as abstract as a service
endpoint or URL.
The metric is how
you're trying to make
that measurement, something
like request count,
or latency, or something
bespoke to you, like number
of customers that are
using a certain resource.
From that ID, you will
get a set of time series.
That's what's shown here at top.
This is the raw data
for CPU utilization
across multiple projects and
instances in different regions.
The first thing to do
in Cloud Monitoring
is to align the data.
This way, all the data
is regularly sampled
and is a summarization of the
raw data point in each window.
In this case, we've chosen
to do Align Next Older, which
means, for each window, we
take the most recent point
and move it to 1, 2, 3, 4,
or other minute boundaries.
Now, every time series is a
line, so we can aggregate them.
We can aggregate all of
them into one time series.
Now we have the
mean CPU utilization
across our entire fleet.
Often, we also want to
break this mean utilization,
as a summary, down, in
this case by region.
And now we have regional
mean utilization.
Both alignment and
group [? buys ?]
are going to be
very important when
you want to configure the
Alert Policy in the next steps.
To talk about
alignment, it's best
to describe how an Alert
Policy is actually evaluated.
So here is a raw set of data.
We picked an alignment
period of five minutes.
What does that mean?
It means take all the points
in the five-minute window.
In this case, calculate
the mean, which is 2.
Then, alerting kicks in.
We set the threshold,
which is 13.
And then, we decide a duration,
which is three minutes.
The way the threshold
works is, it says,
are these points indicative
of the condition being active?
Then, the duration
says, is the condition
active for three minutes?
In this case, none of
the points indicate
that the condition is active.
So the alert doesn't fire.
Alerting is real-time.
So then, we move
to the next minute.
And we say, over this
five-minute window,
what does the query return?
The query returns a
different value, still
below the threshold.
And when it returns
the different value,
then we apply the duration
window a second time.
And we say, none of the points
are above the threshold.
The alert doesn't fire.
We repeat again and
again, until there
is a point above the threshold.
The alert, however,
still doesn't fire.
Duration is telling you,
over the whole 3 minutes,
are all the points, all the
queries above the threshold?
It's not the case until here.
Now all three points
are above the threshold,
and the alert fires.
Your phone goes off.
You get an email, or any one
of your other notification
channels that are
configured, are fired.
The alert we'll
continue to be active.
It's a real-time system.
We're continuing to check
that the alert is active
until the alert finally
stops being active.
The first time we get
a query point that's
below the threshold, the alert
is now considered inactive
by Cloud Monitoring.
And you will get a
resolution notification
on any of your
notification channels.
And that is the end of how
an Alert Policy is evaluated.
From here, I'll now send it to
Rory to actually demonstrate
some use cases of alerting
and Cloud Monitoring.
RORY PETTY: So the
first demo that we're
going to present is creating
an alert query, where we'll
get into a lot of the concepts
that Syed just mentioned,
in terms of alignment,
filtering, aggregation, et
cetera.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We'll start by looking at
an example Kubernetes cluster.
Here we see the demo cluster
with five different nodes
and several different
microservices running on pods.
Now, normally, we
would recommend
using Service Monitoring
to create SLO-based alerts
for monitoring your
microservices running
on Kubernetes in production.
However, today,
we're going to do
just the simple
infrastructure-based alert
to illustrate some of the
concepts behind alerting.
So we'll go into
Cloud Monitoring.
We select Alerting
here in the Left Nav.
And let's click Create Policy.
So let's start by creating
an Alert Policy that
will alert us if the GKE node
CPU utilization goes too high.
We click Add a Condition.
And we'll search for the
Kubernetes node resource type.
And then let's select CPU
Allocatable Utilization.
Once we select that, we see
a couple of different options
appear here in the left column.
Filtering lets us
reduce the amount
of data returned for a metric
by specifying filter criteria.
This removes some
data from the chart
by excluding time series that
don't meet that criteria.
For example, we see
here, we have time series
for five different nodes.
But if we click on
Filter, we can filter down
those available time series
by project ID, location,
node name, a bunch
of different options.
In this case, let's
select node name.
And we could say, that
we wanted to filter
by all of the nodes that start
with a certain string prefix,
like GKE/demo.
Or we could say,
very specifically,
we want to filter and show only
this specific instance ID name.
As you can see, once
we selected the filter,
now we only have a
single time series.
Group By works by identifying
sets of time series
that all meet some criterion and
then combining or aggregating
the members of
those sets together.
Grouping is done on the basis
of resource and metric labels.
For example here,
we go in, and we
can group by project IDs,
location, cluster names,
user metadata labels,
system metadata,
lots of available options.
So in this particular
case, let's go ahead
and group by location.
We see here, all
of our time series
were replaced by a single time
series in a single location, US
Central1-a.
And another way that you
can kind of understand this
is, if we removed the Group
By, and the aggregator--
let's go back here and
look at our Legend.
If you notice here, the legend
contains different columns
or label keys.
So if we go ahead
and select these,
we see all these time series
have these different label
values--
location, cluster name,
project ID, et cetera.
So again, Group By
lets us reduce down
to a single time series--
or pardon me-- it
lets us reduce down
to time series grouped
by a single label value,
in this case, location.
Aggregation lets us
combine time series
by using common functions,
sometimes called reducers.
The available reducing
functions depend on the type
of values the metric captures.
But they commonly
include choices
like mean, max, min, standard
deviation, assorted percentile
values, other kind of
statistical operations.
When used with grouping,
the reducing functions
are applied across all of
the selected time series,
combining them to a single
time series consisting of mean,
sum, or other measure, as is
calculated across all the time
series.
So when used with
grouping, again,
this function is applied to the
time series within each group.
So again, just to see
how that would work,
if we select Mean here, we're
taking the mean or the average
across those five time series
produced by all of our nodes.
And here, we see a
single time series there.
Or perhaps, we want to look
at the 99th percentile, which
is useful for latency metrics
or many other kinds of metrics.
Now, we'll go into
Advanced Options here.
And if you remember from
Syed's demonstration earlier,
one of the most important
fields to set for Alert Policies
is the alignment period.
So take for example, an
alert that you specify
where you want to say, alert me
if my CPU utilization is over
90% for 10 minutes.
If you remember
from Syed's talk,
the for-10-minutes part is
actually the alignment period
that we want to set.
What this does is it says,
look at the last 10 minutes,
and take all the raw points
that have been written
for a given time series.
And then, apply an aligner,
which, in this case,
it defaults to a mean aligner.
So effectively, take
all those points,
average them, and produce a
single point for the last 10
minutes that will be used
as part of our evaluation.
So we'll go here, and we'll
set just an arbitrary threshold
so that we can talk to
this a little bit better.
But now that we
have a threshold,
we can see our points have been
aligned using the mean aligner
over the last 10 minutes.
And here is how the time
series are evaluating.
We have three of them that are
below the threshold and then
two that are above.
So now, if we scroll
down to Configuration,
we see the next
important option,
which is, this
alert condition will
trigger if, the
default option is,
if any time series violates--
so if we scroll up
here, we can see
that, because there are
two above the threshold,
this would go ahead and trigger.
There are also options for
percent of times series.
You could say, I want
50% of my time series
to be above or below the
threshold, 75%, whatever
you're interested in.
You can pick an exact number,
like two of my time series,
three of my time series.
Or you can say, all
of them have to be
above or below the threshold
for the condition to trigger.
Now, for the
condition, we can say
that we want these
time series to be
above or below the threshold.
We can say that we want
them to be changing
by a certain percentage.
So perhaps, in a
dynamic environment,
I want to be alerted
if my latency increases
by 90% or 100%,
something like that
or, if, in a steady
state environment,
if something decreases
by a certain percentage
in a short amount of time.
Lastly, there's also an
option for absence alerts.
But we'll talk about
that in another demo.
Lastly, this "for"
option, refers
to the duration setting
that Syed also spoke
to you in his demonstration.
For most people, for
threshold-based alerts,
we recommend setting the value
here to the most recent value
such that, when
the time series go
above or below the threshold,
you are alerted immediately.
Now, if you'd like to use
duration or a duration value
to reduce false positives,
you can do that.
For example, we could
say that, the time
series must cross the
threshold and must
remain above the threshold
or remain in violation
for a three-minute
period for the alert
to trigger, which will,
again, reduce false positives,
but also has the risk
of making your alert be
less likely to fire based
on the shape of your data.
And we'll have a
demonstration later
that illustrates that point.
So now let's go ahead
and save our condition.
We'll also add a
notification channel so
that, when our alert fires,
we can be notified on email,
Slack, PagerDuty, et cetera.
So we'll go ahead
and say that we
want an email to be sent to
you [? foodexample.com. ?]
And lastly, we'll put in
some documentation that
explains to the
person on call how
they might attempt to remediate
the issue caused by the alert.
So we might say that they
should check the database logs.
They should check the amount
of allocatable CPU quota
for the pods, et cetera.
Now we'll go ahead
and save this policy.
Now we see a graph here,
again, of our time series.
We also see
incidents that will--
this is where, once the
alert starts firing,
incidents will appear.
Now we can go ahead,
to see what that
looks like, we can go into our
list of existing incidents.
We'll select one of them.
And here, we see in
the message field,
it tells us exactly what
resource this particular GKE
node caused the
alert to trigger,
based on a certain time series
value over our threshold.
We can see the graph
here of all of our nodes,
so that we can easily
compare the node in violation
to the performance
of the other nodes.
And we see some labels here,
that help us, again, zero down
into and figure out
what the exact resources
that's causing our issue.
Lastly, we can also link out
directly to logs and other ops
management tools, to
help us figure out
what the root cause
of the problem is
and to remediate the issue.
[END PLAYBACK]
RORY PETTY: For our
second demo, we're
going to talk about
absence alerts
and how they differ slightly
from threshold-based alerts.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- To illustrate the concepts
behind absence alerts,
let's go ahead and select
a log-based metric that we
created from one of
our App Engine apps.
And in this example,
the App Engine app
was spun up at
this point in time.
It started to write logs.
And then, we disabled
the app, at which point,
it stopped writing logs.
As you can see
here, this graph is
expressed as a rate,
which is why it's spiky.
It's how frequently the
log is being written.
In our case, for
an absence alert,
we really don't
care about the rate.
We want to just see the count
or the number of time series
points that were written
for the log-based metric.
So in this case, we will apply
a count aligner, which gives us
a nice, smooth line here.
Again, we have kind
of a step function.
We see missing data
or absent data here.
Here is metric data.
And then, it goes absent,
again, right here.
- In order to create
an absence alert
for this metric, what you want
to do is focus on the bottom.
You want to say, instead
of condition is above,
you say is absent.
Then, the threshold
will go away.
And underneath the "for,"
you have the amount
of minutes that you actually
worry about this metric being
absent before your
phone goes off
or before you get another
type of communication.
In this case, we'll
choose 10 minutes.
And the last thing here
is clicking, again,
on Show Advanced Options.
You'll note that, if you want
to aggregate-- so for example,
you don't care that this
logs-based metric is
absent for any
specific custom label,
but you care that the
metric doesn't exist at all.
You may want to
pick an aggregator.
When that happens, you will need
to pick an aligner like count.
For alignment period, we
suggest just picking one minute.
That way you don't
have to think about it.
And you can focus on
the important parameter,
which is the amount of time
that the metric is absent.
[END PLAYBACK]
RORY PETTY: In our
third demo, we'll
discuss how alignment
period and duration interact
with each other and how
it affects whether or not
your alerts fire reliably.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- To further illustrate the
differences between alignment
period and duration,
let's look at an example
here, where we're starting
to see a real spiky
increase in network traffic.
We've selected the received
bytes metric for our GCE, VM
instance.
We see over here, our
received byte count,
which is spiking up
and down over time.
We've also filtered
this down to the traffic
sent to a very specific
VM, the demo VM.
And so we've gone
down here and said
we want to be alerted
if the time series
values are above this threshold
for an amount of time.
Let's say, we want
to be alerted if it's
above the threshold
for 10 minutes.
Now, naively, this
might make sense.
But will this alert
fire every time
the line here on the graph
crosses the threshold?
- And the answer is no.
Based on the
demonstration earlier,
we know that we care about
the 10-minute summary of bytes
received.
To do that, we should not change
this field in the "for" field.
Instead, we should go
to Advanced Options,
pick an alignment
period of 10 minutes,
and then, pick a
statistic that we like.
In this case, right over 10
minutes sounds reasonable.
This is the average
bytes received per second
over every 10-minute window.
You could see that the
curve is smoother, better
representing the fact that you
care about a 10-minute average.
After this, for the "for"
field, which wasn't 10 minutes,
the best thing to do is to
set this to most recent value.
That way, every time this smooth
line goes above the threshold,
your alert will fire.
And your alert will not flat.
Because remember, you
have a smooth curve.
It's going to take some
effort for that curve
to come back down.
- So now that we have correctly
set the alignment period
and duration values, let's go
ahead and save this condition.
And one other thing that
we want to illustrate
is the ability to add multiple
conditions to an alert policy.
When we want to detect a
ping storm is happening,
we're interested not only
in the received bytes
for one VM for our demo VM.
But we're actually interested
in the behavior of another VM.
So let's go ahead and
look at our GCE instances.
And in this case, we're
interested in CPU utilization
for a different VM, this one
by the name of Instance 1.
So now we see that, now
that we filtered down
to this particular
instance, we see here
that Instance 1
CPU utilization has
been pegged at 100% for
quite some time now.
So we might want to say that,
if our CPU utilization is
over 90% for a 10-minute
alignment period,
then alert us when the
most recent value crosses
the threshold.
We'll go ahead and
click Add there.
You see now that we've
added two conditions.
We have another
option that the policy
will trigger when it defaults
to any condition is met.
So if either of these
conditions trigger,
you'll receive an alert.
You also have the option to
say, if all conditions are met.
So both would have
to-- both conditions
would have to be true.
And then lastly, in
our case, we will
select All Conditions are Met
Even for Different Resources
for each condition.
So if you remember, in our
case, the first condition
was filtered down to
the instance ID demo.
And the second condition
was filtered or predicated
on the instance ID Instance 1.
So this has been an example
that not only illustrates
both the interrelationship
between alignment and duration,
but also how you would
combine multiple conditions
within your Alert Policy.
[END PLAYBACK]
SYED ASHRAFULLA: And
that is it for our intro
to alerting and
cloud monitoring.
RORY PETTY: Thanks
for listening.
And have a nice day.